connaissez-vous la génération
farniente parce qu'elle périt c'est
l'objet de votre livre aux éditions de
l'archipel une allergie au travail qui
gagnerait la jeunesse et même au-delà et
qui menacerait notre modèle social à
prendre très très au sérieux selon vous
voilà dans l'invitation de Baptiste
garguichartier on en parle avec vous
juste après
si on vous invite Pascal Perry c'est
pour le coup de gueule que vous poussez
contre la paresse illustration dans
votre dernière ouvrage génération
farniente un essai polémique qui aborde
des amours du travail de toute une
génération vous y apportez un point de
vue économique historique et social
qui choisissent plutôt l'assistanat
plutôt l'assurance sociale telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui distribuée en France on
va leur dire vous devez désormais
préféré le travail ça ce serait une
vraie révolution
Pascal Perry vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et chef d'entreprise votre
ouvrage le plus marquant sans doute
celui sur le pouvoir d'achat mais dans
votre dernier essai vous proposez une
réforme du système économique
si on veut conserver le modèle qui est
le nôtre il faudra travailler plus en
quantité en qualité retenez une idée
simple le travail c'est le seul capital
de ceux qui n'ont pas de capital il faut
donc le préserver
dans votre ligne de mire travailler plus
pour une société solidaire votre tête
s'appuie sur des statistiques vous
comparez la France à ses voisins comme
l'Italie l'Allemagne ou encore les pays
nordiques puis vous revenez sur des
faits marquants qui ont façonné notre
rapport au travail
d'abord mai 68
la crise sanitaire ou encore la réforme
des retraites
votre récit prend suite une dimension
plus politique lorsque vous critiquez la
gauche actuelle sur ses positions
relatives au travail discours que vous
jugez irresponsable vous travaillez
moins pour travailler tous et mieux en
sommes là oui endroit la paresse oui on
trouvera la Ret
raite la gauche d'aujourd'hui milite
dans certains cas pour la disparition du
travail dites-vous Pascal Perry vous
dites que la France est confrontée à un
vaste mouvement d'allergie au travail
alors une question comment guérir cette
allergie
une bonne question d'abord la formation
la question de la formation qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure avec les
parlementaires il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont hors du travail parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la bonne formation il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont de mauvais
revenu qui ont des revenus insuffisants
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de formation donc
je crois que tout commence à l'école
vous savez au fond l'emploi c'est
l'étage supérieur de l'étage éducation
avec notre système éducatif dans votre
lit vous parlez d'école du travail mâché
oui et je pense que le goût de l'effort
ne s'apprend plus tout à fait il y a des
responsabilités partagées moi je
rencontre des professeurs qui sont
parfois un peu désespérés des parents
qui se comportent un peu comme des
consommateurs vous avez une quand
j'étais jeune quand l'instituteur
notait mauvaise remarque sur le carnet
de notes mais mes parents m'en parlaient
pour promener c'est lui qui a raison
aujourd'hui quand ça se produit de la
même façon vous avez des parents qui
vont voir le le professeur pour
l'engueuler ça c'est absolument
inacceptable il faut respecter le savoir
respecter les connaissances et puis
c'est vrai qu'il y a un fond général
dans la société peut-être que la société
du 20e siècle a été structurée autour du
travail que le temps de loisir le temps
de famille s'articulait d'abord autour
du temps professionnel il y a
aujourd'hui une génération de jeunes
gens qui font écouter d'ailleurs avec
des compétences des appétences
complètement différentes qui considèrent
que le cocon familial la vie personnelle
celle au centre de la vie et que au fond
le travail est un élément satellite le
seul problème
c'est générationnel non uniquement parce
que c'est une chose de ne pas vouloir
travailler plus longtemps et ça a le
rejet il était massif dans la réforme
des retraites aucune réforme des
retraites entre nous n'est populaire
mais c'est une autre de considérer que
on veut vite aller se reposer on veut
vite en finir et que le travail rend
malheureux est-ce que c'est notre cas
France vraiment moi je crois pas que le
travail rentre malheureux je pense que
d'abord un discours politique mais je
constate en même temps qu'il y a ce que
j'appelle une génération Netflix
deliveroo qui a élu le canapé comme le
le centre du monde et qui est
extrêmement passive alors en quelques
minutes c'est compliqué d'en parler il y
a l'école il y a probablement l'éruption
du digital dans la vie qui fabrique
plutôt des individus passifs que des
individus actifs il y a un fond de l'air
politique on a entendu Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui nous dire faut travailler
moins travailler tous mais pardon on a
l'expérience des 35 heures le chômage a
massivement augmenté en France il suffit
de constater que les statistiques le
disent pour le croire le chômage à
massivement augmenté après la réforme
des 35 heures la réduction du temps de
travail
donc absolument la réduction du temps de
travail n'a pas créé d'emploi en France
non je crois qu'il faut travailler sur
les qualifications et ne pas oublier un
principe fondamental qui est un peu le
cœur de ma réflexion la France a fait un
choix historique qui est de faire
financer son modèle social par le
travail par les actifs par les actifs et
donc c'est la quantité de travail dans
la société et la qualité du travail donc
la productivité qui finance le modèle
social qui est le nôtre
si nous avions si nous avions le taux
d'emploi des Allemands ou celui des
Danois nous aurions en France et sa
réglera une partie des problèmes qui ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure 100 milliards
d'euros de recettes publiques
supplémentaires est-ce que vous rendez
compte de ce qu'on peut faire avec 100
milliards d'euros donc si tout le monde
se met à travailler si la quantité de
travail est suffisante dans la société
une grande partie de nos problèmes y
compris budgétaires sont réglés
fond
de commun oui mais vous travaillez plus
nous permettrait véritablement de
beaucoup mieux vivre il y a quelque
chose qui est fondamentalement invisible
et retrancher sur chose tout ça traduit
une société de d'égoïste bien sûr le
sens de la solidarité c'est un petit peu
perdu heureusement d'ailleurs qui a
encore une vraie sécurité sociale
des institutions sociales en France
parce que c'est ce qui permet de verser
les retraites c'est ce qui permet de
soigner les gens dans de bonnes
conditions de
politique de l'enfant mais ce que leur
portage tout à l'heure le petit résumé
était très bien parce que moi je pense
que le fait générateur c'est l'échec de
la réindustrialisation du pays c'est le
milieu des années 80 il y a deux écoles
aux partitionniste et le Parti
socialiste qui gouverne c'est François
Mitterrand et président de la République
il y a l'école Edith Cresson qui dit
mais la désindustrialisation n'est pas
une fatalité il faut réinvestir
moderniser l'outil de travail
délocalise les bras d'une en partie mais
on conserve de l'industrie en France et
puis il y a le l'autre école qui
l'emportera finalement qui est celle de
Martine Aubry qui dit après tout les
pertes industrielles c'est le produit de
la mondialisation on va on va on va
imaginer une économie de service du
temps libre etc ça nous a mené dans le
mur ça car les Allemands nos voisins ont
choisi d'investir massivement non pas
dans la retraite à 52 ans ce qu'on a
fait dans la sidérurgie dans le textile
mais dans la modernisation de l'outil de
travail c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles aujourd'hui l'Allemagne reste
un pays industriel c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles on s'est
désindustrialisé et on en a fini par
considérer qu'il était normal de ne plus
travailler à 52 ans comment voulez-vous
que dans une société les gens est envie
de travailler quand on leur envoie des
signaux comme celui-là les 35 heures
alors vous êtes très dur d'ailleurs avec
la classe politique avec la gauche en
particulier vous parliez de du fond de
l'air tout à l'heure c'est vrai que les
slogans contre la réforme des retraites
ont pu interroger on a retrouvé
quelques-uns mais trop boulot tombeau
voilà la retraite on s'en fout on veut
pas bosser du tout boss consomme crève
droit à la paresse on envoie
quelques-uns pour vous la gauche
radicale aujourd'hui est la première
responsable on entend descendre une
Rousseau est-ce que vous ne lui donnez
pas un peu trop d'importance qu'elle n'a
en réalité dans l'opinion je pense
qu'elle a une à la qualifiée de
dangereuse je crois qu'elle a un impact
culturel fort c'est le
changement d'opinion enfin la production
de l'opinion sa réponse souvent à des
logiques minoritaires il faut 5% de gens
très convaincus pour faire une
révolution les autres suivent en général
non je crois qu'on a une gauche
aujourd'hui qui sur la base d'un rapport
de Terra Nova d'ailleurs au début des
années 2010 disait la classe ouvrière
est perdue la classe ouvrit a été
pervertie par le capital si vous voulez
pour dire les choses simplement les
nouveaux révolutionnaires sont dans les
cités dans les banlieues c'est les
luttes intersectionnelles et vous avez
aujourd'hui une gauche qui dit
clairement mais comme Sandrine Rousseau
je ne l'ai pas inventé une bonne sieste
pour remplacer le capitalisme ou qui dit
oui ni loi ni travail au moment de la
loi el khomri ni loin Nitra donc ça ça a
un impact évidemment et comment France
on a une politique extrêmement généreuse
comme on sort d'une période d'argent
magique ça alimente cette idée que au
fond le non travail est possible qu'on a
totalement décorrélé le principe du
travail et le principe des revenus du
travail alors vous reprenez la formule
de Sylvain qui dit que la France est un
paradis peuplé de gens qui se croient en
enfer cette idée que la France est un
enfer social vous avez vraiment le
sentiment qu'elle est majoritaire dans
le pays
tout à l'heure on veut faire la poche
des pauvres non c'est pas sérieux le
syndicat majoritaire à la CGT mais
est-ce que c'est ce qu'on entend il y a
dans l'espace on vit dans une société
d'opinion c'est pas vous qui me direz le
contraire
l'opinion est déterminante c'est elle
qui produit une espèce de récit
collectif mais la voie de la majorité
n'est pas entendue elle est très peu
entendue on entend beaucoup des voies
réfrigérateurs oui heureusement qu'elle
s'exprime dans les urnes mais là on ne
parle pas d'élection on est en train de
parler du fond idéologique dans la
société et en effet il y a une
sur-représentation de de cette parole
qui remet en cause les grands équilibres
qui oublient de rappeler que le travail
produit la protection sociale qui
voudrait
désigner une partie du pays comme le
principal responsable des des malheurs
collectifs les riches de façon générale
en oubliant
écoutez et de faire en sorte qu'on
retrouve un peu ce goût de l'effort et
du travail pour le bien commun de tous
et donc pour nous écoutez on vit dans un
pays formidable on est assuré sur un
social de la naissance à la mort
l'Etat et les organismes sociaux
couvrent les aléas de la vie ça il faut
le protéger et la meilleure façon de le
protéger c'est de travailler allez
tout c'est à dire aux éditions de
l'archipel vous restez avec moi Pascal
per